[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA SIMMONS: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the Authors
at Google talk.
My name is Jessica Simmons.
And I'm a director in gTech.
And it's my pleasure to
introduce you to Dorie Clark.
Dorie is here today to discuss
her newly released book,
"Entrepreneurial You."
Dorie is an author
of several books,
including "Reinventing
You," "Stand Out," which
was named the number one
leadership book of 2015
by "Inc." magazine and
one of the top 10 business
books of the year by Forbes.
Dorie is an expert
in self-reinvention
and helping others make
change in their lives.
She is a frequent contributor to
the "Harvard Business Review,"
a professor at Duke University's
Fuqua School of Business,
a Grammy-winning jazz
producer, and consultant
who speaks for organizations
like the World Bank, the Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation,
and Yale University.
Please join me in
welcoming Dorie Clark.
[APPLAUSE]
DORIE CLARK: Thanks, Jessica.
I was 22 years
old, and I had just
gotten out of graduate school.
And this was my first job.
I was a newspaper reporter.
And it was kind
of an amazing job.
I worked for the alternative
news weekly in Boston.
This is actually the very
first cover story I had.
It's not above the fold,
but it's still pretty good.
[LAUGHS]
But one day, something changed.
We went from covering all
of the most important issues
of the day, all the really
good stuff you can see up here,
to me getting called
into the HR office.
Now, it turned out I left
that afternoon without a job.
I was shocked.
And you might say, Dorie, duh!
You were a newspaper reporter.
How could you not
expect to get laid off?
But the truth was, things
really were different back then.
It was 2001.
And we forget now in
retrospect, but the year 2000
was the best year in history
for the newspaper industry.
Newspapers were
rolling in money.
It was at its peak in
advertising revenue.
But of course, as we've
seen in the years since,
the years in which nearly 40%
of American journalists have
lost their jobs, that sometimes
things can change overnight.
Oftentimes, when things are
in that moment of transition,
we are not able to see it.
We can't perceive it clearly.
So I woke up the next morning
after getting laid off.
And I said, well, you know, I'm
just going to get out there.
And I'm going to have
to look for another job.
But it didn't quite
work that way.
It turned out that the day
that I had been laid off
was Monday,
September 10th, 2001.
I woke up the next morning.
And me being out of a job was
the least of anyone's problems.
Now, today, many of you guys are
working in robust and growing
industries.
We're here speaking at Google.
Google is doing very well.
But of course,
what we've learned
is it's not just
industries that can change.
It's also jobs that can change.
We know from our own experience
that the things that we're
hired to do today may be very
different from the things
that we're wanted and
expected to do down the road.
There's a gentleman that I
interviewed for my first book,
"Reinventing You," Stephen
Reiss, who at the time
was a high-ranking HR
executive in Silicon Valley.
He told me that one of the
questions that he always
asked the most senior candidates
when they were coming in
for their final interviews
was, how are you
reinventing yourself?
Not are you
Not how would you
reinvent yourself?
But how are you presently
reinventing yourself?
He wanted an answer.
And if he didn't
hear one, he said,
they were not fit
because the number one
skill, the foundational
skill, that we all
have today is adaptability.
If you have that,
you can evolve.
You can change.
You can move in to
the new direction
and make your
transition seamless,
regardless of what's going
on in the outside world.
If you don't have that, things
can often be quite difficult.
Now, I know for
Google, for instance,
that one of the
foundational principles
is encouraging you guys to move
around within the organization,
to build new skills,
to try new things,
which I think is
incredibly important.
We have to keep
pushing ourselves.
But what I've come to
realize in those years
since I was first laid off--
since I started out
as a journalist,
I've reinvented myself.
I've become an author.
Today, as I'm speaking,
we have a new book
that I just launched, called
"Entrepreneurial You."
I've started to teach
and be a professor.
I consult and speak.
But mostly, I've been doing
research about this question,
about how, in the
modern workforce,
we can still succeed, even with
everything changing around us.
And so today, I wanted
to share with you
some of the fruits of that
research over the years,
about strategies that
we can all employ,
not just entrepreneurs,
not just people running
their own businesses, but people
who have day jobs that they
love, strategies
about how we can all
be more entrepreneurial,
think more entrepreneurially
in our work.
Because when we do
that, that's not just
about a methodology for
starting a business,
it's about a way of being.
It's about embracing
adaptability.
It's about leaning
in to the changes
that we need to make to make
ourselves indispensable.
So let's talk a
little bit about that,
about how we can think
more entrepreneurially.
I want to start
with a little story.
This is Todd Herman.
Now, when I'm talking
to people about starting
to think entrepreneurially, one
of the questions that I get,
one of the things
you hear all the time
is, OK, that all sounds great.
But what if I'm
starting from nothing?
What if I am in a
place where I don't
have a lot of connections,
I don't have a lot of clout?
How can I even begin
to get started?
And so sometimes the answer
is right in front of us.
Todd Hermann grew up
in Western Canada.
And he loved sports.
He was a high school
football coach.
But he specialized in
something a little distinctive,
mental toughness.
That was his hook.
He talked about how
to win the inner game.
And so he started to develop
a sideline in addition
to the regular
coaching he did, where
he would coach athletes, high
school and college athletes,
on a private basis.
He knew that in order
to get more business,
he'd have to get
himself out there.
He'd have to somehow
win new clients.
And so he decided
to do something
pretty simple, pretty basic,
that almost any of us can do.
And that is talk for
free about his ideas.
He put the word out to
youth sports leagues
around where he lived in
Western Canada and said, hey,
I will come speak to
your team for free.
But there's only one catch.
For every player
that's there, they
need to have at least
one parent in attendance.
And the reason he
did that was he
knew that if he just
delivered the message
to the high schoolers,
that would be great,
but the buyers of his
services, the parents,
wouldn't be in the room.
So he began to do
these free talks.
And he did a ton of them.
Within 90 days, he
had done 60 talks.
Sometimes it's about
putting in the effort.
It's about putting
in the sweat equity.
But within those 90 days,
something transformational
happened to Todd Herman.
Yes, he got more
coaching clients.
It worked.
But that's not the real story.
What also happened was something
that he never expected.
In the audience,
some of those parents
had interesting jobs
where they realized
that a mental toughness coach
could actually be something
that they could use as well.
One of the parents
turned out to be
an executive with the
National Hockey League.
He said to Todd, could you
come in and coach our players
in the NHL?
One of the parents
who was in attendance
was a senior leader within
the Canadian government.
That person said
to Todd, would you
be willing to come in
and talk to my office?
The Canadian government
needs what you offer.
Todd had never even thought
about expanding his business
from coaching teenagers
to coaching adults.
But when the opportunity
presented itself, he took it.
He sprung into action.
And today, Todd has a business.
He lives here in New York.
He has a business coaching
everyone from senior executives
to Olympic athletes.
If you want to think
entrepreneurially,
you have to accept
that sometimes, you
are going to start from zero.
You won't have any connections.
But if you get scrappy,
if you're willing to work,
if you're willing to
seize opportunities
when they come to you, you can
make your own opportunities.
Not having the connections
now is never an excuse.
Now, another area that
I hear a lot from people
as we talk about how to begin
to think more entrepreneurially
is you hear a lot
of times people
say that they have
an idea that they've
been nurturing for a while,
sometimes even years.
And it's been spinning around.
But they haven't done
anything about it.
And that always makes me
a little bit sad because
of course, if we're
not sharing it,
then it's not having
an impact in the world.
The things that we want to
accomplish aren't getting done.
And so that's why
this gentleman's story
resonated with me so much.
His name is Michael
Parrish DuDell.
He actually wrote the book
for the television show,
"Shark Tank."
But when he got his start as an
entrepreneur a few years ago,
he did something that I
think we can all learn from.
Now, as Michael was
thinking about consulting
and writing and speaking and
doing all the things that he
would as an entrepreneur,
he realized he could
he could certainly
do all the tasks
that would be involved
in his business.
But there was something
that he had never
done that was essential to
really knowing how to think
and act entrepreneurially.
He had never sold anything.
And if you want to
be an entrepreneur,
or you want to think
like an entrepreneur,
you know that you need
to be able to sell.
It doesn't necessarily
mean literally
sell a product or
service, but it
means you have to sell an idea.
It means you have to learn
how to be persuasive,
how to close a deal,
how to make the ask.
He knew he couldn't
be successful
if he didn't know
how to do that.
And so he challenged himself.
Unlike so many people
who talk and don't act,
he gave himself a deadline.
He said, I am giving
myself 30 days.
If I do not sell a client,
if I do not land business
within 30 days, I'm
going to give up,
and I'm going to go back
to what I was doing before.
And he did it.
Sometimes if we light
a fire under ourselves,
if we force ourselves
to take action,
it can propel us out of the
inertia that is all too often
part of the human condition.
It could be getting an
accountability partner.
It could be posting
on social media
and letting people
know that you're
going to do something so
that you embarrass yourself
into doing it.
Because otherwise,
people will know.
But however you decide to do it,
if there is an idea, a project,
an initiative that you
have been thinking about,
that you have been
nurturing and cultivating
in the back of your
mind, maybe it's time
to bring it to the
front of your mind.
Another lesson, maybe
the most central one
of all, when it comes
to entrepreneurship,
is about the importance
of testing and iterating.
That's why in
"Entrepreneurial You,"
I profiled this gentleman.
His name is Danny Iny.
He's an entrepreneur
based in Canada.
And when he first started in the
world of online courses, which
is an area that he has a
lot of expertise in now,
things did not go well.
That's the thing
about entrepreneurship
and entrepreneurial thinking.
It's not always a rosy story.
Right?
That's why some people shy away
from it because the results are
not guaranteed.
It doesn't always work.
In Danny's case, he launched
a course, rather ironically
titled Marketing That Works.
And he ended up
selling one copy.
Painful.
That is the moment we all dread.
That's why so many people
don't take that chance.
But he learned something
important from it.
And I think that you and I
can learn from his lesson.
When he launched Marketing
That Works, he had a concept.
And his concept was, I
have found all the things
that people need to
know about marketing.
Now, I will tell it to them.
And he thought the world
would come running.
But of course, they didn't.
Now, so often, what happens
when we are launching new ideas,
new projects, new initiatives
is that we cook up something
that we think, that we
assume that people will want,
but we never test that premise.
We never validate it.
We never actually go out
and talk to the customers.
And so we make our guess.
And our guess turns
out to be wrong.
Danny told me that he spent
six months of his life creating
this course for this one guy.
He says if he actually
factors it out,
he probably made about $0.17 an
hour for the work that he did.
So the next time--
this took a few years.
You can imagine.
He was gun shy after this.
Next time he decided he wanted
to launch an online course,
he knew he was going
to do it differently.
He was not going to make
the same mistake again.
And so what he did this time,
which has actually become
a classic-- it has become
a standard move for online
courses and I think should
probably be a standard move
in just about everything we do--
is that when he launched
his next course,
he hadn't created the course.
What he did was he sent
an email to his list.
And he said, hey, guys, I'm
thinking of creating a course.
Here's what it would be.
Here's what it would cost.
If you're interested,
you can sign up here
at a discounted price.
You can be the beta testers.
And in exchange for
more interaction with me
and your honest opinion and
feedback about the course,
we can do it together.
That course sold out.
And by the time he was
able to fully launch
after doing his test pilot,
he was totally confident
that the course was what the
market needed and wanted.
Because he had gotten
direct response
from his audience about exactly
what they wanted and needed.
That was the way that he was
able to test it and validate it
without putting in the
huge amounts of effort that
in the case of the first
course were totally wasted.
If we can learn in our
entrepreneurial thinking
to always test and
iterate, to place,
in the words of the author
Peter Sims, those little bets,
the bets that are small enough
to give us data, the bets that
are small enough that,
if they don't work,
it is not the end of the
world, that we can look at it
and say, OK, no worries.
I'll go on to the next thing.
That frees us up to double down
on what actually is working.
Which leads us to metrics.
Right?
How do we know,
with all the things
that we're doing, with
all the possibilities
out there in the world,
how do we know what it is
that we should be focusing on?
That's the challenge.
Right?
This is a woman
named Natalie Sisson.
Natalie is an entrepreneur
from New Zealand.
And when I interviewed her--
she's today very successful,
makes a quarter of a million
a year with her business.
Doing great.
When I interviewed her
for "Entrepreneurial You"
and asked her what
it was is she most
regrets about the early
days of her business,
she said that when
she looks back,
she felt like she
was working so hard.
She felt like she was really
putting in the time and effort
and making progress,
building her brand.
But what she was
actually doing, sometimes
for up to eight hours a day, was
interacting with people online.
She was on social media.
Now, she wasn't
watching cat videos.
Right?
This is not someone who was
wasting her time in overt ways.
She was doing things that
she felt were valuable.
She was making friends,
building community.
She was posting on LinkedIn.
She was interacting
with people on Facebook.
She was tweeting.
We look at that
sometimes, and especially,
in the social discourse
about business,
we think, oh, that's
how you do it.
That's how you build a brand.
That's how you build a platform.
But one of the
crucial distinctions
we need to make if
we're going to learn
to think entrepreneurially
is understanding
that sometimes the
things that we're doing
might have the
illusion of progress.
They might have the
illusion of being effective.
But they're not really.
Because when it
comes down to it,
an online connection
like that, especially one
built on someone
else's platform,
is usually a pretty weak tie.
What she says she wishes that
she had done early on instead
was to spend that time creating
content, building out products,
having something real that she
could offer to people to sell,
and also, especially,
building an email list
so that she could communicate
with people directly
and unmediated by other
people's platforms, which,
of course, are subject sometimes
to the vagaries of algorithm
changes and shareholder
preferences.
We need to know
always, if we're going
to think entrepreneurially,
what metrics really matter.
Not the illusion of
progress, the ones
that really make a
difference for us.
If we can focus there,
if we can focus our ROI,
we can really begin
to move the needle.
Now, I've been making
the case to you guys
that entrepreneurial thinking
matters for all of us,
even if you work inside a
company, maybe even especially
if you work inside a company.
I want with this story
to actually take it
even one step further and
say that it's not even
just entrepreneurial
thinking, but even
sometimes entrepreneurship
can make a positive difference
for your corporate career.
This is a gentleman
named Lenny Chan.
He's someone I feature
in "Entrepreneurial You."
I first got to know him when
I was consulting for the Mt.
Sinai Hospital here in New York.
And when I was doing this
consulting engagement,
everybody was
talking about Lenny.
And at the time, I
was wondering why.
What's up with this guy?
Why is everyone
buzzing about him?
And the reason was, he had
actually started his career
as a nurse at the hospital.
And by the time I met him,
he had advanced so rapidly,
been promoted so
much, he was now
running communications for
the entire hospital system.
That is not a
traditional career path.
How had he done that?
And so when I first met him at
a meeting we were at together,
I asked him, what gives?
How did you get here?
And what he told me
is that along the way,
he had become fascinated with
apps, with smartphone apps.
And so he got interested
in that and decided
that he was going
to figure out how
to develop a couple of them.
And so he did.
He launched them.
He put them up, made
them publicly available.
And it was his side project, his
entrepreneurial side project.
Now, he didn't make a
million dollars from them.
But he was making money.
And he learned a lot.
But all of that,
possibly, he thought,
was going to come crashing down.
Because one day he got
a call from his boss.
His boss said, Lenny, I hear
you've been developing apps
on the side.
And Lenny said, yes, I have.
His boss invited him
into the office, wanted
to chat with him about it.
Lenny was petrified
because he thought maybe
he had violated a policy
he hadn't known about,
maybe the boss
thought that he had
been doing inappropriate
things on company time.
That wasn't it.
His boss said, Lenny,
we need someone
to run social media
for the hospital.
I think it should be you.
His boss saw what Lenny
did on his own time, nights
and weekends, his own
effort, his own initiative,
and he recognized
it as leadership.
The old model, the
scarcity mentality model
that many people
had in the past was
that an entrepreneurial
side venture threatens
what you do at your day job.
The smartest bosses today know
that that is completely untrue,
that instead, the way
that you spend your nights
and weekends matters.
What are you doing?
Is it better for you to be
watching television, or hanging
out in a park?
Or is it better for you
to be learning new skills,
trying something on your
own, learning lessons
that you can apply and bring
back to everything you do?
In Lenny's case,
his boss saw that.
And he ultimately
did such a good job
running social media
for the hospital,
he got promoted to run
all of communications.
Today, Lenny actually works
at a different hospital.
He's the head of innovation.
He has transformed
himself in his career
on the strength of what he
decided to do and to learn,
what he decided to make himself
on his nights and his weekends.
Now, another element
of entrepreneurship
that I think we can all
learn from in the realm
of entrepreneurial thinking
is about constraints.
Just like in poetry,
sometimes the best poetry
gets written under the
direst constraints.
It's not necessarily
easy to write sonnets,
to write a villanelle
or a haiku.
There's constraints that we face
that force us to be creative.
And similarly, in the world
of entrepreneurial thinking,
we all face constraints.
Whatever you want to
be doing, you probably
don't have as much budget
as you would really like
to be able to accomplish that.
You probably don't have
as much staffing help
as you would like.
You may be under
tight time pressures.
But oftentimes, those
things, those very things
that are so vexing
in the moment,
can actually inspire greater
creativity, can get you
a better result in the end if
you embrace the limitations.
This is a gentleman
named Jason Gaynard.
Jason faced a constraint.
A few years back, he
was heavily in debt.
He had built a business for
himself reselling tickets.
And it had done
well for a while.
But it wasn't his passion.
And he had managed to
get really in debt.
He had a baby daughter.
And times were a little
bit strapped for him.
One morning, because
of his baby daughter,
he was up at 4 o'clock
in the morning.
And that was when
an email came in.
It was an email from Tim
Ferriss on his mailing list.
Some of you guys may
know Tim Ferriss.
He's the popular author of the
book, "The Four Hour Workweek."
And Jason was on his email list.
Tim was launching a new book.
And he was trying to
sell a lot of copies.
And so he had just
put out a notice
that there was a special deal.
There was only one
slot available.
If someone in advance of
the launch of Tim's new book
was willing to buy 4,000
copies of his new book,
Tim would come and do
two speaking engagements
for that person.
This was $80,000.
Jason absolutely did
not have $80,000.
And he also had
no idea if he were
to have Tim Ferriss
available, what he would even
have Tim Ferriss do.
But he saw that email and
said, this is an opportunity.
Someone is going to take that.
And a minute later, he
said, it should be me.
And so he emailed back.
Without any money in the bank,
he accepted the $80,000 offer
from Tim Ferriss.
He reckoned he had
two to three days max
to somehow find the money.
He went to his friends.
He had a pretty good network
because he had spent time
over the years investing
in his friendships
and in his professional
relationships.
And went to three friends.
One friend had too many
questions and wanted to know
what would it be for,
how would we do it.
Jason didn't have time.
He moved on to the next one.
The next one was excited, but
wanted to do way too much.
He wanted to start a
business with Jason.
He wanted to launch
a whole endeavor.
Jason didn't have time for that.
He went to the third friend.
The third friend said,
I'll cut you a bank check.
Be here tomorrow morning.
He got the money.
He still didn't know what
he was going to do with it.
But he found a way.
What Jason ultimately decided
to do was launched a conference.
He called it Mastermind Talks.
And he would make Tim
Ferriss the keynote speaker.
He would make him
the star attraction.
But of course, he realized
if he was spending
$80,000 on Tim
Ferriss, he did not
have any budget for
any other speakers.
What can you do?
How do you get around that?
Well, something
that he realized was
that it wasn't just him that
was excited to see Tim Ferriss.
A lot of people would be
excited to see Tim Ferriss.
And not just fanboys.
Tim Ferriss's friends
would be excited to see
Tim Ferriss because oftentimes
they're ships in the night.
They're all traveling around
to different conferences.
They don't get to hang out.
Jason decided that
he would invite
a whole fleet of
top notch speakers
that were in Tim Ferriss's
orbit and were friends of his,
but people he didn't
get to see that often.
He would ask them
to speak for free.
And the winner of a competition,
the attendees of the conference
would vote, would
get a $30,000 prize.
For everybody else,
no compensation.
Amazingly, they did it.
Jason was able to organize
an entire conference based
around having Tim Ferriss and
a bunch of people that wanted
to hang out with Tim Ferriss.
The conference was
a rousing success.
He decided to make it elite.
At first, he wasn't sure
how much he could charge.
But eventually,
he realized if it
was a small, private,
curated event,
he could charge a lot of money.
Eventually, he
settled on $3,000.
He brought his money in.
He was able to pay off
the Tim Ferriss debt
that he had borrowed
from his friend.
He was able to
make money from it.
And he was able
to launch a brand.
It's now called Mastermind
Talks, a conference.
He's been doing them
about four years.
These have become such elite
and exclusive conferences
that the price tag,
$7,500, is actually
quite close to what it costs
to attend a TED conference now.
The way that he was able
to come up with this plan
emerged from him
seeing an opportunity
and realizing that the
constraint that he had,
the constraint of no money,
the constraint of not being
able to pay other speakers
could force creativity
in new directions and has
opened up an entire new business
line for him.
That's how we need
to begin to think.
We need to ask ourselves,
not oh, we can't do this.
We can't do this.
We need, in the world of
innovation, as they say,
to start asking
ourselves, we can if XYZ.
If we can understand
what the if is,
if we can reframe
the question, it
opens up sometimes a world
of new possibilities.
As
You heard in the
story about Jason
borrowing the money
from his friend,
no questions asked,
come to the office
tomorrow, pick up the check,
your network matters a lot
when it comes to
entrepreneurial thinking.
The myth, the myth of
entrepreneurship, of course,
is the stories that
we tell that we
love to pass down
like lore that's
it's about guys in garages
tinkering by themselves.
That's not how it works.
Much more likely
and much more often,
it's about a community of
people helping each other.
And this is a story about that.
This is Dov Gordon.
Dov is a marketing consultant.
And he wanted to build his
business, like a lot of people.
He also realized he
didn't have a lot of money
for marketing expenses.
And so he was trying to
figure out, how could he grow?
How could he get in
front of new people
without shelling out a lot
of money that he didn't have?
He realized that something
that would work really well
was affiliate promotions.
If, for instance,
I promoted him,
and if someone that
I had recruited
went to do business with him,
he would send me a commission.
If we're able to do
that, that's a great way.
You don't have to pay
anyone for marking expenses
until the client and
the cash is in hand.
But how do you find
affiliate partners?
One of the ways that he was
able to start doing that was he
decided he would
start a community.
He created something called
Joint Venture Marketing
Mastermind.
It's very simple.
It's a listserv.
In fact, it's a Google listserv.
And it exists today as a group
of about 100 to 150 people
who are supporting each other.
They don't have to do business
with any particular person.
Nothing is required.
But he's convened a
community of people
that he has
hand-selected who reflect
online entrepreneurship
done the way that he
wants to see it done.
This is not hard sell tactics.
This is not sleazy operators.
These are the people that
he respects in this space.
And he brought them together
to be able to do business
with one another.
Now, that helps him.
And he's actually been
able to grow his email
list by over 10,000
people and get thousands
of dollars of business as a
result of what he put together.
But even more than that,
he's helping 150 other people
grow their business as well.
The core of
entrepreneurial thinking
is looking for
those opportunities
where we're able to have a
win-win, the opportunities
where we can help ourselves
by helping other people.
This does not have
to be about growth
at the expense of someone else.
The best growth, the most
lasting and sustainable growth,
is about growth
through helping others.
A question I hear
a lot though as we
go into this journey
about entrepreneurship
or entrepreneurial
thinking is about, how
do you stay on target
during the hard times?
In between starting out and
actually succeeding in the way
that we want to succeed,
there are a lot of roadblocks.
There are a lot of times
where you are not sure if you
are making any progress at all.
It can become incredibly
disheartening and incredibly
destabilizing because
you wonder if you're
making a huge mistake.
You wonder if you'd be
better off quitting.
That's why the story of
Stefanie O'Connell, I think,
is so instructive.
Stefanie moved to New
York with a lot of hopes
and a lot of dreams.
She wanted to be a
Broadway actress.
But she realized
early on that if she
was going to make
it in New York,
one thing she had to
get straight right away
is her finances.
Because this is an
expensive place to live.
She actually started a blog
to help her keep on track.
She called it "The Broke
and Beautiful Life."
And in it, she started
sharing her lessons,
the things that she
had learned about how
to be smart about your money.
Her blog started to get popular.
She started to feel like it
was gaining some traction.
Maybe it could be something.
But of course, it takes a while
for a blog, or anything else,
to really succeed.
Today, Stefanie is a recognized
personal finance expert.
She's been on television.
She writes for
major publications.
But the way that she was
able to stay focused,
and something that,
I think, more of us
need to understand and embrace,
is that if the only thing
you're focused on, if the only
goal that you're headed toward
is oh, well, I won't have
succeeded until I get a book
deal, or I won't have
succeeded until I get on TV,
or I won't have succeeded until
I get this promotion to SVP,
that is a long time in coming.
What we need to do is learn
to focus on the small wins.
We need to learn to
understand and recognize
that the signs of
progress are things
that need to be seen and
appreciated and celebrated.
Because that's what
will keep us going.
She told me that she remembers
vividly the first time
that an influencer
that she respected
retweeted one of her posts.
That's a small thing.
But it showed her that
someone she cared about
was paying attention.
She remembers vividly
the first time
that instead of blogging
for free like she
had done for months
and months and months,
someone offered
her money to blog.
It was $25.
That is not a lot of money.
But she said, that's two hours
I don't have to be a waitress.
And it's a sign that someone
values what I'm doing.
When we see those things,
when we recognize them
for what they are,
which is as a signpost
that we are moving toward
where we want to go,
that is how we can
stay on target.
That is how we can
keep going, even
in the face of discouragement.
That's what we need to be doing.
Now, Stefanie's story ties
in to an other point that
is critical here, which is that
you can't give up prematurely.
If you do, you oftentimes
may have been on the path
to success, but you fall off
just a little bit too quickly.
There's a study that was done
by a researcher named Josh
Morgan, which I found stunning.
In 2015, he did a
study of podcasts,
a longitudinal study over the
past 10 years, 2005 to 2015.
What he realized, number one,
there's a lot of podcasts.
At the time that he studied
this, 206,000 podcasts.
That number has only
grown since then.
If all we look at is
that top line number,
we say oh, 200,000 podcasts, how
could I ever compete with that?
Why should I even start if there
are so many people out there
trying to reach
that same audience?
How can I ever break through?
What Josh Morgan discovered
though is something
that I think if we
really understood,
if we really kept in
mind, might actually
transform how we do everything.
And that is out of
those 200,000 podcasts
over this 10-year period,
the average podcast
lasted only 12 episodes before
its creators stopped doing it,
12 episodes.
There was an average
of two episodes
a month for six
months, and they quit.
We think we're competing
against 200,000 people.
We are not.
If you simply persist, the
ranks thin so dramatically,
you're competing against a
fraction of what started out.
This gentleman here,
Jordan Harbinger,
he runs a podcast called
"The Art of Charm."
It's very popular now.
It's in the iTunes top
50 business podcasts.
It's hard these days with a
lot of big corporate entrants.
You know, there's NPR,
major, big funded shows.
Jordan runs an independent
podcast that is still
one of the most popular.
Three million people
a month download it.
How did he get there?
Well, it turns out he's
been doing it for 10 years.
Who even had heard
of podcasts in 2007?
But that's when he started.
And he's been doing
it ever since.
It starts slow.
He told me he remembers the
first time he'd actually
looked up his
podcast statistics,
26 people had
downloaded his podcast.
He said, not 2,600, 26 people
had downloaded his podcast.
And he said, he found
it so depressing,
he didn't look at his stats
for another six years.
But he kept going.
And today, he's built
a massive audience.
We have to, as
entrepreneurial thinkers,
learn to outlast
the competition.
Now, I also don't want
to leave the impression
that the only metric of success
is about huge podcast numbers,
or having some massive reach.
That is a great
thing to aspire to.
If we persevere, we
may, in fact, get there.
But we don't have to get there
in order to be successful.
As we saw with the story
of Stefanie and focusing
on the small wins,
there's a lot of good
that can come even before you
break through in a huge way.
This is a woman named Fei Wu.
I actually met Fei a few years
ago because she is a podcaster.
She had me on her show.
As I got to know Fei, I
realized something incredible.
Now, she has a small podcast.
It does not have
the download numbers
that the Jordan and
"The Art of Charm" does.
But she has nonetheless
been able to build
a business for herself on the
back of having this podcast,
not because she's getting
lucrative sponsor dollars.
That hasn't happened yet.
But what's happened is something
perhaps even more surprising.
A full 25% of the
guests on her show
have actually gone on to hire
her for business projects.
And it all started not
because she pitched them,
not because it was ever a
plan to get them as clients,
but because she learned about
these people, cared about them,
got to know them.
And she'd make suggestions,
like sending a list to people
about ways that they might
improve their website
and its functionality.
Now, this was not a ploy
to get them to hire her.
These were things they
could all do on their own.
But she had developed such
a strong rapport with them
that when they found out
that she did branding,
that she did web design, they
reached out and said, well,
could you do this for us?
We would love to hire you.
And she's built a successful
entrepreneurial venture
for herself as a result,
really, of the relationships.
That's a metric
that we can focus
on is, how do you build
deep relationships
with your audience, with
the people around you,
with your community?
Which leads me to the last
point, the last story,
about how we can all start to
think more entrepreneurially.
This is Pat Flynn.
Pat also is a blogger
and podcaster.
But his story is a
little distinctive.
And when I learned about
it, I realized there
was an important lesson in it.
Pat actually started out working
for an architecture firm.
And during the Great Recession
in 2008, he lost his job.
He had actually just
passed an exam though.
He had been studying
for a while to get
certified in green
buildings and being
competent in the
green building world.
And in order to study
for this exam, which
was pretty hard to
pass, he had set up
a blog, where he was posting his
study notes and all the things
that he was learning,
just so he could really
keep himself focused.
And he thought, hey,
maybe my efforts
can help some other
people as well.
His site had become
pretty popular,
because there was useful
information on it.
So it began ranking pretty
highly in search engine
results.
So eventually Pat
decided that maybe he
would take his blog posts
that he had written,
that he had shared for
free, and he put them
together as an e-book,
just an easy way for people
to start reading it
all in one place.
So he puts all of his blog
posts together as an e-book,
puts it up on his website.
And something kind
of amazing happened.
His first month
selling the e-book,
he brought in nearly
$8,000 from doing it.
That was stunning
to him because it
was more than twice as
much money as he was making
at the architecture firm.
And the timing was pretty
good, because he had just
gotten laid off.
But of course, when
he realized that this
was starting to take off,
he wanted to understand it.
He wanted to understand why
people were buying this book,
so he can learn more
about his customers
and why they were doing it.
So he sent out a survey.
And he asked people, why
did you buy the e-book?
How did you hear about it?
And he realized something
kind of astonishing.
A full quarter of the
people who wrote back
to him about the e-book
said that they had already
passed the green building exam.
They didn't need
the book any more.
He said, well, why did you
buy it if you don't need it?
And they said, Pat, we've
been reading your blog.
And this is the first time that
you've ever sold something.
And so it's the first chance
we had to pay you back.
Think about that for a minute.
If you can have the
kind of relationship
with your customers, with your
audience, with your community,
with the people around you
so that they care enough,
that they value
what you do enough
that they would be
willing to buy something
they don't even need as a
thank you, that's a testament.
Obviously, we don't
want to be selling
people things they don't need.
But think about the emotion
and the sentiment behind that.
If we really want to be
entrepreneurial thinkers, if we
want to embrace
flexibility, adaptability,
thinking about what the
audience wants and needs,
and being able to deliver
that in innovative ways,
one of the best things we
can do is to ask ourselves,
how can we create a relationship
with that community such
that they would want to purchase
something just as a thank you?
How do we get them to value
what we're doing that much?
If we can reach that level,
we will have succeeded.
So today, we all
live in a busy world.
You know this.
A study by the
Radicati Group in 2015
showed that the average
professional sends or receives
122 email messages per day.
That number is
only getting worse.
It is only compounding.
A study by the
Eliassen Group said
that the average professional
spends 62 hours per month
in meetings, well
over a full workweek.
It's a week-and-a-half
in meetings.
But if you think about
it, it averages out.
Two or three meetings a
day, it's probably right.
62 hours a month.
We are being pulled in
a million directions.
Everyone's attention is frayed.
And amidst all of this,
we have massive change,
technological change,
disruption, new innovations,
new trends, new geopolitics.
Somehow we have to adapt.
Somehow we have to make
ourselves indispensable.
The more we can think
entrepreneurially,
the more we can learn to
bring these ideas together,
to embrace them, to make
them a part of our lives,
the more successful we
can be over the long term.
That's why I wrote
"Entrepreneurial You,"
to be able to try to provide
a playbook for people
in today's economy to go a
little bit further and think
about how we can bring
this into our own lives
and our own careers.
So today, I've laid out
11 different strategies
about how we can think
more entrepreneurially.
Some may resonate with you.
Others might not.
It's a smorgasbord.
But if you can take just one
or two and begin to apply them,
begin to make them a
part of your life, that's
how we can really create career
insurance for ourselves moving
forward.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]